la domanda che vi rivolgo oggi è può
l'evoluzione dell'uomo procedere oltre
la biologia
partiamo dal 1859 charles darwin
pubblica l'origine della specie dopo
cinque anni di viaggio attraverso i
continenti
a bordo del brigantino beagle raccolse
un gran numero di campioni che gli
permise di formulare la teoria del
trasformismo biologico che mette in
relazione le caratteristiche biologiche
di una specie con l'ambiente in cui essa
vive
pochi anni dopo nel 1866 mendel pubblica
i suoi studi riguardanti l'esistenza di
determinanti ereditari quello
l'esperimento che tutti conosciamo come
l'esperimento sui piselli mendel
intervistato da un giornalista
dell'epoca disse i miei studi mi hanno
dato grandi gratificazioni e penso che
non passerà molto tempo prima che il
mondo intero riconosca l'importanza dei
miei risultati il suo ego era enorme
però aveva ragione perché nel 1906
lo studio la scienza che studia
l'ereditarietà venne ufficialmente
nominata genetica e i determinanti
ereditari citati da mendel vennero
nominati i geni fu nel 1953 che gli
studiosi watson e crick fotografarono
per la prima volta ai raggi ics una
molecola di dna
in realtà non andò proprio così loro
riuscirono a ricostruire la struttura
del dna perché la fotografia in realtà
un'altra ricercatrice però a loro fu
assegnato il nobel per la chimica mentre
la ricercatrice non assegnarono nulla
detto ciò oggi sappiamo che piccole
modifiche organiche cioè piccole
modifiche del dna si presentano negli
individui nel tempo e tali variazioni
possono essere in parte
per la legge della probabilità
vantaggiose per gli individui che le
presentano e quello che viene definito
adattamento biologico ma per l'uomo è
ancora così molti lo definiscono
adattamento culturale
l'uomo da sempre una grande capacità di
adattarsi agli ambienti in cui vive è
ciò che per il singolo individuo può
essere sfavorevole viene avvantaggiato
dall'utilizzo di strumenti che possiamo
definire tecnologie e quella che vedete
alle mie spalle e una tecnologia che
risale a circa 2,5 milioni di anni fa
nel paleolitico l'uomo incomincia a
costruirsi degli strumenti in pietra che
gli facilitano alcune attività ad
esempio in questo caso un coltello in
selce che poteva essere utilizzato per
tagliare la carne oppure per sfogliare
gli animali e farsi degli abiti di pelle
e addirittura in questo modo permettere
all'uomo di andare a colonizzare quelle
parti del pianeta molto fredde che
quindi erano molto svantaggiose dal
punto di vista della vivibilità che cosa
succede quindi all'uomo quando per
problematiche fisiche deve comunque
rimanere attivo nell'ambiente in cui
vive
mille avanti cristo egitto viene
definito la luce del cairo è il primo
esempio di una protesi ad un uomo a cui
manca una luce viene fornita una protesi
in legno e cuoio che gli permette di
continuare a camminare normalmente è
davvero affascinante pensare che sia
stata progettata tremila anni fa la
medicina nella storia umana ha
un'evoluzione esponenziale
pensate che nel 1668 in olanda il medico
giovane keren eseguì il primo innesto
osseo eterologo cioè prese il frammento
del cranio di un cane e lo inserì in un
difetto craniale di un soldato ferito in
battaglia
siamo nel 1600 immaginate la reazione
della chiesa
il soldato fu immediatamente scomunicato
e chiese al medico di poter estrarre
questo frammento ma non fu più possibile
perché il frammento del cranio di cane
si era perfettamente integrato nel
cranio umano nel 1928 sir alexander
fleming per caso come spesso succede nei
laboratori di ricerca e sviluppo scoprì
che la muffa penicillium la muffa forma
di pennello era in grado di inibire la
crescita di alcuni microrganismi
oggi sappiamo che da quella buffa fu
estratto e purificato il primo
antibiotico la penicillina
da questo momento in poi lo sviluppo
delle tecniche chirurgiche non ebbe più
limiti infatti nel 1954 a boston
joseph murray eseguì il primo trapianto
di reni fra gemelli omozigoti si
trattava dei fratelli ronald e richard
harris allora avevano 23 anni
l'intervento dura 5 ore e mezza ma fu un
grandissimo successo
questi sono solo esempi di evoluzione
culturale in ambito biomedico
ma la storia moderna ci dimostra che
questo tipo di evoluzione esponenziale è
avvenuta su molte altre tecnologie è
forse l'esempio più così affascinante
risale al 1969 precisamente il 20 luglio
quando gli astronauti neil armstrong e
buzz aldrin potevano passeggiare per due
ore e mezza sul suolo lunare un ambiente
che dal punto di vista dell'abitabilità
è proprio impossibile
e allora tutto sta evolvendo sul piano
tecnologico ma che cosa può comportare
la mancata selezione naturale su ciò che
riguarda invece l'evoluzione umana
la risposta è
probabilmente niente l'astrofisico
stephen hawking in un suo talk disse
sono diecimila anni ormai che non si
registrano delle modifiche al dna umano
dovute all'evoluzione biologica
tuttavia la quantità di conoscenza
trasmessa di generazione in generazione
è cresciuta enormemente quello di cui
abbiamo parlato fino adesso evoluzione
culturale
quindi oggi possiamo ipotizzare che
l'individuo più forte è forse quello che
meglio si adatta all'evoluzione
tecnologica o in futuro ai cambiamenti
climatici e ai fattori di rischio
ambientale che addirittura l'uomo stesso
ha creato ma c'è un passaggio successivo
che possiamo fare in questo ragionamento
possono la scienza e la tecnologia
essere esse stesse motore
dell'evoluzione biologica nel 2014
la dottoressa lewis ad harvard insieme
al suo gruppo di ricerca hanno per la
prima volta al mondo bio stampato in 3d
la parte di una parte di un nefro né
durante un suo talk in una conferenza in
canada in cui avuto la fortuna di
partecipare la dottoressa lewis disse
stiamo testando la funzione la struttura
di unità modulari con l'obiettivo di
assemblare un singolo nefro le calcolate
che in un individuo sano adulto sono
presenti all'incirca tra gli 0,8 e 1,5
milioni di neuroni per ogni renée
non siamo vicinissimi all'obiettivo
finale ma questo è un tassello molto
importante per quello che riguarderà la
tecnologia del 3d printing di organi
umani
inoltre nel 2017
ad auckland sul 44 enne joseph medio è
affetto da una rara patologia
congenita metabolica denominata sindrome
di hunter i medici effettuarono il primo
editing dei geni la patologia di hunter
si presenta come l'incapacità per
l'individuo che ne è affetto di
sintetizzare quindi di produrre un
enzima che è importantissimo per
riuscire a mantenere la matrice
extracellulare dei tessuti connettivi
intatta quindi è un problema che
riguarda tutti i tessuti connettivi la
pelle muscoli e legamenti
se prima del gene editing la
concentrazione di tale enzima era pari a
zero nell'individuo dopo se ne potevano
registrare piccole quantità piccole
concentrazioni ovviamente non ancora
sufficienti per curare la patologia le
scienze biomediche lo sviluppo delle
scienze aeronautiche e aerospaziali e la
capacità dei calcolatori di aumentare
quindi la potenza di calcolo ci
permetteranno in un brevissimo tempo e
ne parlava bruna silvia di raggiungere
marte e di poterci abitare per un
determinato periodo in un luogo che è
assolutamente impensabile abitare per le
condizioni atmosferiche appunto medicina
rigenerativa avanzata e scienze
genetiche ci permetteranno in futuro di
superare i nostri limiti biologici e
tecnologie di realtà aumentata
ci daranno la possibilità di avere
informazioni riguardo all'ambiente in
cui viviamo che vanno oltre alle
informazioni sensoriali biologiche
voi pensate che passerà ancora molto
tempo prima che si passi dagli algoritmi
di machine learning di cui parlava
federico prima a delle vere e proprie
intelligenze artificiali
se pensate che ci vorrà ancora
tanto tempo lasciate che vi presenti
aurora ciao aurora vuoi spiegare al
pubblico qui in sala che cosa sei sono
un intelligenza artificiale
oltre ad un'elevata capacità di calcolo
delle emozioni quelli sono stata
programmata aurora tu cosa pensi come
sarà l'evoluzione dell'uomo in futuro
l'involuzione sarà senza l'ing grazie
[Applauso]